welcome back everybody it's hard to
define exactly what mathematicians mean
when they use the phrase problem-solving
however you go about it it's going to
involve some notion of approaching
puzzles that you've never seen before
and still being able to systematically
and creatively find some solution to
them but that's a weird thing when you
think about it because it makes it a
very hard thing to teach I mean you can
teach someone how to solve one
particular problem maybe even a class of
problems and teach them how to solve
another problem but how do you teach
someone how to approach a problem that
they've never seen before and still make
progress on it well I honestly don't
know how but what I want to do for this
lecture is to talk through a couple
different problem-solving principles
I've enumerated nine of them in total
and each one we're gonna walk through in
the context of a specific example and I
think each one is kind of simple you'll
look at it and you'll nod along thinking
yeah yeah of course that's the thing
that you should do but I would argue
that each one is deceptively simple that
you would be shocked at how often you
can make very meaningful progress in
very hard problems just by keeping some
of these tips in the back of your mind
and to give you a little flavor for
where we're going to be going today I
want to ask not as a quiz that I expect
you to necessarily be able to solve here
on the spot I want to ask you a question
that we will be solving later on in the
lecture just so you can have it in the
back of your mind a little thing to mull
over any a hard problem that will be fun
to tackle when the time comes
so the question asks suppose that two
numbers are chosen at random from the
range 0 through 1 and it's done
according to a uniform distribution so
maybe you pick like 0.385 and point 5 8
9 6 2 or something like that each one is
chosen at random suppose P is the
probability that the ratio of the first
number to the second rounds down to an
even number so you know maybe it rounds
down to zero or rounds down to 2 or to 4
and basically it's asking you to guess
where is this probability you know we'll
solve it exactly we'll get an exact
expression but just intuitively as you
hear the problem when you think of
choosing two random numbers between 0 &
1
looking at their ratio what do you think
that probability is going to be well
return back to this later and one thing
I want to say is that this whole live
quizzing software it's something that's
built by some friends of mine Ben eater
who many of you may know because of his
YouTube fame and then another person who
used to work with us at Khan Academy
named kam Kristensen and this is just
one small little outcropping of what's
actually a much deeper product at play
and I want to give you a little preview
of some of the other things that they've
been working on that will be developing
so if any of you want to share some of
the lectures here or go back and kind of
go through the live quizzing experience
if you go to the link that it's in the
description but it's at item pool comm
/c / 3 b 1b but you can follow the
description you can basically watch the
lectures in a way where you can do these
live quizzes along with it and your
progress is tracked and you get scores
and things like that so as you skip
ahead to various different questions it
will skip you to the right point in the
video and as the video plays forward
you'll also get to yeah there's just me
talking through some problem you'll also
get to whatever the appropriate part of
the problem is they often have
explanations associated with them and
hints and things like that and
ultimately if you look back in just a
couple days I'm going to fill out like
homework and challenge problems so if
you like challenging problem solving
contest math type stuff I'm gonna put
things that are relevant to the lectures
in there which I think should be fun
it's not not quite there yet but
definitely check back and I'm sure just
over the next couple months there will
be more item portion Anakin's going on
if any of you want to use this maybe to
do some live polling in your own live
classes for teachers who are dealing
with the whole remote landscape or if
you have your own streams anything like
that
they are looking for beta users so feel
free to reach out to them it should be
available on the website now let's dive
into the actual content shall we some of
the nine deceptively simple
problem-solving tricks and before we do
I want to specify that at some point
today in the next hour I'm going to
purposefully make a mistake okay and I
tell you that for two reasons one so
that you keep your eye out and you you
know you're a little bit skeptical of
each of the claims that I make and two
so that when I make that mistake and you
notice it and you're just you know
throwing things at the screen you're
getting angry you're clicking that
unsubscribe button you can at least
quell a little bit of what you're
thinking so just keep that in mind there
will be one very purposeful mistake now
before we get to the problem solving tip
I want to talk about
geometry this is one thing I was hoping
to do a little bit more of in this
series but this would be just a fun time
to give a little example of it and in
particular I want to talk about one of
my favorite little bits of geometry it's
not too simple but it's also not too
hard it's called the inscribed angle
theorem it comes up way more than is
reasonable for a simple little theorem
like this to actually come up when
you're solving problems okay and
basically an inscribed angle of a circle
refers to if you have two lines that
meet at a point of that circle and what
we care about is this little angle in
here okay and if you were just studying
this if you're an early mathematician
trying to make sense out of this you
might make a guess that something about
this angle is going to be related to the
arc of the circle that those lines hit I
mean that arc can also be described as
an angle of some kind if we draw lines
from the center of the circle it makes
it a little bit clearer so I'm just
gonna draw a couple green lines here and
Mark that we have a different angle here
and maybe I give them names I'll call
this one theta L for like the large
angle and this one I'm gonna call theta
s it's the small angle and you might
wonder is there a relationship between
these two angles and if so what is it
and for our purposes today the question
is how do you systematically approach a
puzzle like this find a relationship
between these two and prove prove its
existence so problems of problem solving
tip it's not problems if problem solving
tip number one which is just just so
useful in a way that again is kind of
deceptively simple make sure you're
always using the defining features of
whatever your setup is I swear a good
70% of the problem sets that I did as an
undergraduate math major essentially
came down to looking at what was given
asking very critically what is the
definition of each term involved here
unraveling those definitions and then
just seeing how they pieced together so
use whatever's the defining feature in
our context what is defining the various
points and intersections that we have
here well it's the idea that they're on
a circle a circle is by definition all
of the points
that are a common distance from the
center so in particular we know that
this length is a radius of the circle
and this length is a radius of the
circle we should use the fact that those
are the same but moreover this other
point P that was not just chosen at
random it's defined to be on the circle
and unraveling what that means it means
it is a common distance away and it's
the same distance away from the center
as these other points so I and then
inspired to draw a line to add something
to the picture and to note that it's the
same there you know quite often when you
see people solve hard geometry problems
it comes down to adding something to the
picture and the most beautiful geometry
involves adding something that seems out
of left field and it just illuminates
everything you shift your perspective
and sometimes you look at him you wonder
like how would you have known what to
add like I get I'm supposed to draw an
extra circle here or put a you know put
a rectangle around this triangle
whatever it is you're doing but how do
you how do you systematically know what
you should add so in this context if it
relates to the definition of your
objects probably a good idea and that
line actually will be helpful to us we
can start giving a couple things names
that's something that a hint maybe it
shouldn't even be described as a tip but
I've put it down as number two that when
you give things meaningful names that
actually helps you move forward in your
problem and in this context it might
seem like an innocuous thing I'll call
this little angle that we formed with
our radius alpha and this little angle
beta and just to see if that helps us
move forward you know recognizing if
alpha and beta show up elsewhere rather
than me telling you I would like you to
tell me in the context of our next quiz
question so before I answer that
probability one for you I'm gonna pull
up question number two for today we've
got a diagram essentially what we just
drew the dot in the middle is the center
of the circle and I've labeled seven
different angles I've just labeled them
a through G and what I want you to do is
tell me which of these equations is true
one possibility is that four of the
angles a B D and E have a sum that's the
same as C plus F plus G which just
looking at C F and G that would be 360
degrees right the other is that a is
equal to B and D is equal to e another
possibility is that C is equal to
F and then maybe it's all of those or
maybe it's none of those and it looks
like we already have strong strong
consensus on this one with 360 400 just
a strong large number of people coming
in agreeing what they believe the right
answer is and you know if you if you
want to be involved the place to go 3 B
1 B Co /live that redirects you to an
item pool page so that you can follow
along and for those who are watching in
the future maybe you're watching it in
the embedded page where the problem is
just sitting right below you and even if
you're not technically participating in
the data contributing to the live
statistics what I was going through it
it's honestly pretty fun to just kind of
looking like I know I'm not a part of
this but it kind of feels like I am a
part of what was happening so I just
love it
alright so because there's such strong
consistence consensus
I feel comfortable grading this I
thought I got it right on one one one
one so the correct answer is that a is
equal to B D is equal to E and then none
of the others are necessarily true and
let's let's walk through why that's the
case yeah it comes down to exactly what
we just highlighted that these radii are
common which means you know let me just
give more things names let's call this
point a and this point B maybe that's
confusing cuz I was just naming angles
and B but separate contacts separate
picture you know what I mean the
triangle a P and then the center of the
circle that's isosceles you know there's
this symmetry about I could even draw
the little axis of symmetry and that
tells us that this is also alpha
likewise the triangle up here is
isosceles and that tells us that this
has an angle of beta and what we just
did in effect is leverage a little bit
of symmetry in this case it was
innocuous but quite often looking for
symmetry in much harder setups it's
super generalizable and it definitely
will help you move forward if you
recognize that there's something
symmetric use that symmetry in some way
which is effectively what we've just
done giving things a couple more names I
might want to call this angle I'll call
it something related to the alphas so
maybe I just call it alpha Prime and
similarly this angle over here is beta
Prime and by noting those facts I have
everything I need to do to draw a
connection between
this small angle and this large angle we
essentially just write down the facts
that we have based on the triangles
we're looking at so the triangle with
all of the Alpha angles the sum of those
angles has to be a hundred eighty
degrees and there's two different alphas
in there and then there's an alpha Prime
and instead of writing a hundred eighty
degrees of course we like radians so I'm
going to say that equals PI radians
similarly the one with all of the betas
tells us that if we take two times beta
and we add beta prime that's also PI and
then the other fact that we have that
just popping right out from the image is
that alpha prime beta Prime and theta L
add up to 360 degrees or two pi so just
writing down all of the relevant facts
that we have now we have some objects
that we can manipulate and work with to
draw some kind of conclusion which again
we're looking for a connection between
theta small and theta large and I know a
lot of you you're three blue and brown
audience members you know about the
inscribed angle theorem but I really
want you to think about this from a
beginner's mind right if you were just
approaching this and you didn't
necessarily already know about it what
would you have done to find that
solution and what principles can you
take away as you do that because that
helps us as we start to get to harder
and harder geometry setups so in this
context once I have these three
equations recognizing that there's an
alpha prime here and one here there's a
beta prime here and one here I might
think about cancelling them out so I'm
gonna you know add this top equation and
maybe I've subtract off the other two
equations and to subtract these off and
what that means is the Alpha prime gets
cancelled so does the beta prime I'm
left with my large angle I'm subtracting
off two times alpha plus beta you know
each of those get subtracted off with
the coefficient two and then we have two
pi minus two copies of Pi so that's all
equal to zero which is saying the same
thing as theta L is equal to two times
well rather than writing alpha plus beta
I'll just recognize that that is the
small little angle that we had it's two
times the small angle again I can't
emphasize enough just what a weirdly
useful fact this turns out to be in
various geometry puzzles you might do
it's definitely come up on the channel a
number of times in circumstance
regarding you know complex numbers or
pure geometry situations of course just
anytime you want to relate an angle to
two times that angle realizing them in
the context of a circle like this can be
strangely useful so this is just an
image to have burned in your mind as
you're solving problems and to give you
one example of a problem that you can
solve once this is sitting there burned
in the back of your mind I want you to
remember back to the lecture that we did
on trigonometry which conveniently it's
actually the example that I had pulled
up here so one of the central things we
were talking about was how just playing
with graphs you can get this
bizarre-looking fact that if you square
the cosine function you get something
that looks again just like a cosine
graph and you can get more exact about
that where if we start with an initial
cosine graph and you manipulate it a
little you know we shift it up we scale
it down we say we need to double the
frequency you get the exact same graph
so we have two different expressions for
the same thing but it's not at all
obvious why these would be related one
of them involves doubling the angle it's
a reference to the other involves
squaring the output okay so it's an
obvious fact we proved it using complex
numbers but what I'd like to do is try
to prove this using geometry to kind of
viscerally see the fact pop out right in
front of us and to do that let's go
ahead and write down what the fact is
again so that we can start thinking
about it we want to find that the cosine
squared of theta which is just saying
take the cosine of theta and square it
it's that awkward notation is equal to
1/2 of 1 plus cosine of 2 theta
you've got the strained relationship
between squaring things and doubling the
angle which as we've talked about in the
whole series is really a reflection of
the fact that a cosine is a shadow of an
exponential function but let's say you
didn't know that we want to see if this
relating geometrically so you don't
already know the double angle identities
or anything like that you just want a
very direct understanding of this
particular equation
well one common thing that comes up is
that a way to show the two non obvious
things are related or even equal is to
see if you can find one object that you
can describe in two different ways so
we're going to look for one object that
we have two different descriptions of
and this often can give you nice
equations in this context it might mean
relating the left and right hand side
this comes up in combinatorics all the
time when you have a counting puzzle
where you know you do something like
count how many ways you can have a
string of five bits that are either
zeros or ones and on the one hand you
can count it multiplicatively kind of
going through each one and saying well
you're multiplying the possibilities by
two but on the other hand you can go
iteratively and say well how many of
them have no ones how many of them have
one one two ones
something that kind of seems harder and
a more awkward way to count but by
describing the same thing twice you end
up with this really not obvious fact
from an algebraic standpoint and we're
going to do the same thing more
geometrically here but again just gotta
emphasize how like how general this ends
up being so what we want is some kind of
object that each of these describes and
to do that maybe we just think okay
let's let's draw a unit circle which is
where something like a cosine typically
comes up well for the first time in my
life I drew a quarter circle arc that
wasn't terrible it's not great but
usually that comes out much more
disastrous how pleasing it should not be
so pleased with a terrible quarter
circle great okay so that's our angle
theta right and what does cosine mean in
this context not cosine squared but just
plain vanila cosine well it tells us if
we look at the x-coordinate of this
point
that's the cosine of our angle and so
now I want you to think about how can we
represent the square of the cosine as
some kind of object some geometric thing
that we can point to in this image and
the first instinct might be something
like well let's draw a square off the
side of this you know something with
area to it and interpret it like that
but then there's going to be a problem
if the principle that we're trying to
apply is describing the same object in
two different ways because if we
describe this left-hand side as some
kind of area that would mean that we
have to find another description of that
same area that same object with the
right-hand side but that's going to be
weird because this doesn't involve
squaring or anything like that if it's
just a plain vanila cosine term it seems
much more natural to describe that as
some kind of ratio or maybe some kind of
length
it's just that we need the two theta to
pop up somehow so instead let's seek a
way to describe cosine squared that does
not involve area but is instead
something more of the flavor of a ratio
or a length and in this context the key
comes down to leveraging symmetry again
and it's a sneaky bit of symmetry it's
something we didn't talk about in the
trek lecture but I love it so much I'll
talk about it again if we think of this
angle theta on the one hand it's telling
us the angle between the x-axis and the
line but on the other hand it's also
telling us the angle between the line
and the x-axis and I know that see it
sounds like the same thing but it means
when I say project down the point at the
end of our radius which was length one
perpendicularly onto the x-axis that
length got scaled down by cosine theta
but now what if I do things the other
way what if I say I want to project down
in a perpendicular fashion onto this
line
well again I just have two lines
separated by an angle theta I'm doing a
projection which means it gets scaled
down by the cosine of that angle so now
I'm taking the cosine of theta scaled
down by the cosine of theta and it gets
me cosine squared of theta so cosine
squared refers to this length a portion
of the hypotenuse of our right triangle
if that hypotenuse had a length of 1
which in our unit circle it always does
and incidentally you can show very
similar reasoning that the sine of theta
is this other other portion of that
hypotenuse and this gives you a nice
sort of a clever proof of the
Pythagorean theorem baby of double
projecting based on asking you know is
is this line theta degrees away from
that or is that line theta degrees away
from this it sounds like you're saying
the same thing but it gets you something
of mathematical substance to recognize
that symmetry now why do I say this well
we have a representation of cosine
squared what we want now is to do
something in terms of two theta we just
were thinking about a context where
we're able to relate an angle to two
theta two to two times that angle so
somehow we want to realize this this
angle as an inscribed angle of some kind
of triangle and I'll show you okay how
you can do that but before I do just to
mention another fact that if you
been puzzlingly around with these sorts
of things might be burning in your mind
is a specific instance of the inscribed
angle theorem called Thales theorem so
let's say that that large angle we had
two theta was actually a hundred eighty
degrees and it was pi radians what would
that mean in terms of the inscribed
angle theorem it means that if we take
that diameter of the circle it's 180
degrees it's just drawing out a diameter
and we have an inscribed angle with
lines that hit either end of that
diameter then this angle is necessarily
half of that so what it means is that we
can we can put a right triangle inside a
circle and whenever you do that the
hypotenuse of the right triangle is
exactly the diameter of that circle it's
a very cute fact if you wanted another
proof of it that's not just via the the
inscribed angle theorem there's another
very wonderful leveraging of symmetry
that you can do where basically you take
this point and you say I'm going to
reflect it through the origin reflect it
through the center of my circle and see
where I get and recognize that
reflecting to the center is the same as
rotating the whole image 90 degrees so
if I have rotated the image 90 180
degrees my other vertex would end up at
that same point but now what we have is
a quadrilateral and one of the diagonals
is a diameter of the circle but the
other diagonal is also a diameter of the
circle which in particular means they
have the same midpoint under the same
distance apart and it can convince
yourself a little that implies it must
be a rectangle that could also be a
little side homework problem if you
wanted to chase around the relevant
angles but I think that's a very
beautiful way to think about fales
theorem that you reflect everything 180
degrees and you necessarily conclude it
must be a rectangle which means that
this is a right angle now for our
purposes what does that mean well we've
got a right triangle sitting here that's
from zero we've got one of the points
here another point on the circle let's
inscribe that in a separate circle okay
so I'm going to take a copy of that
triangle but I'm going to instead of
making the hypotenuse a radius of the
circle
I'm gonna make that hypotenuse a
diameter of the circle so this is still
going to be an angle of theta sitting
right here
the basically I flipped it around so
previously I was here but I flipped it
around so that my ninety degree angle is
sitting up unto the right rather than
sitting down here the length that we
care about is what what happens when we
project from the point at that ninety
degree angle in a perpendicular fashion
down onto the hypotenuse which now looks
like this and what we care about is this
long length okay and actually let me ask
you as a is a live quiz to see if you
can come up with an expression for that
length in the context of the diagram
that we're now looking at so pulling up
our quiz again congratulations to
everyone who got this one correct let me
give you a little bit of time to think
about this one because this is this is
kind of a heart part of the heart of
this particulate proof and I think it's
very very pleasing to see so it
specifies that the hypotenuse of the
large bright triangle above has a length
of 1 in our context B is because it came
from the hypotenuse of the triangle
drawn in a unit circle so that potenuse
has a length of 1 what is the length L
in terms of theta yeah so can you find
an expression for L in terms of theta
and I'll give you a little bit of a
little bit of time for that bring back
our pause and ponder music get myself a
chance to take a drink
once again it looks like we have some
strong consensus for today so while
answers are rolling in before I grade it
I'm just gonna go ahead and start
describing how it goes since it seems
like a lot of you are already well ahead
of me it's fun to have though so of
course we're going to use the inscribed
angle theorem that is the whole reason
and bringing it up here it's a way to
relate a single angle to twice that
angle so in this context I would draw
some lines from the centre of my of my
new smaller circle that has radius only
1/2 and recognize that this is 2 theta
and this is just lovely now isn't it
because what is the length we care about
part of it
excuse me part of it is the radius which
is 1/2 but then the projection down
according to 2 theta onto this remaining
leg ends up being that radius 1/2 times
the cosine of 2 theta and of course
that's exactly what we want it to be
we've got the whole radius which is 1/2
and then we're multiplying that by 1
plus the cosine of 2 theta
it's a radius of the circle times a
scaled down version of that radius so
that's two different ways of viewing the
same object which is what we get when we
take this right triangle and we project
down and look at what part of the
hypotenuse that cuts off and it gives us
this non-trivial relationship in
trigonometry between the cosine squared
and the cosine of 2 theta the fact that
otherwise we were going into like
complex numbers and Exponential's to
understand so I think that's quite
beautiful I think that's just one of the
many many instances of where the
inscribed angle theorem suspiciously
lotion
it's just suspiciously shows up and
again what I want you to take away is
this principle that if you can have one
object described in two different ways
very powerful in terms of showing non
obvious how to break relations or
anything that's kind of written down
symbolically without immediate intuition
on top of it so with all of that let's
actually turn to the probability
question that I asked at the beginning
of the lecture so going back to our live
quiz I will go ahead and grade what we
we all now know the correct answer so
for those of you in a minute oh it was
marked incorrectly
oh that's my bad no I just slipped this
one in like last minute before the
lesson today so I I might have like
swapped around what the answers were so
well it looks like 1380 if we were
absolutely wrong according to whatever
jerk wrote this quiz so I don't know how
that shows up on the user interface if
it's like shocking read like oh no but D
was the actual correct answer here so
congratulations to those of you who got
that now back to our probability
question I'm curious to see what people
said on this one just in terms of their
instincts so this one we had a little
bit more of a spread and ah interesting
here the actual correct answer does show
up quite a bit quite a bit lower than
and now I'm questioning myself to make
sure that I've actually written the
thing appropriately so just as a
reminder of what the question is we're
choosing two random numbers from the
range 0 through 1 each according to a
uniform distribution and we're we're
guessing what the probability that they
round down the ratio of these numbers
rounds down to an even number remember 0
is an even number so that it rounds down
to 0 where 2 or 4 or anything like that
now this is a tricky problem to think
about and definitely no no fault at all
for anyone who isn't immediately able to
see roughly where it should be but I
think with a with a little bit of
progress on our way even before we get
the exact solution we can get to a point
where you might be able to intuitively
give some kind of ballpark estimate so
what have we got here
choosing two random numbers between 0 &
1 I think that's a weird thing to think
about especially if you're not familiar
with probability that well or when the
phrase uniform distribution is thrown up
if it's not clear what that means but
essentially it's what you would expect
when you're choosing some random point
on this line and the idea is that each
point is as likely as another or more
specifically a given range of points of
a certain size should have a given
probability that's independent of where
that range showed up it's only dependent
on its size now so you might have in the
back of your mind the idea that we've
chosen two points there each somewhere
between 0 and 1 and just to give an
example of what we mean by uniform
distribution the probability that X sits
between
point three and like zero point five
because it's going to be somewhere
between zero and one and the length of
that range is zero point two about a
fifth of the entire length that could
have come from what it means to be
uniform is that that probability is
actually just the length of the segment
that it came from now one thing you
might ask is well what if what about the
probability that it's precisely 0.3 or
precisely 0.5 would it matter if we made
these less than or equal to signs and
the answer is it doesn't actually matter
because the probability of hitting any
specific value on a real number line
ends up being 0 this is a thing that I
find very confusing
how can a probability of an event that's
possible it's definitely possible to hit
0.3 have probability 0 made a whole
video about it trying to describe this
but really what it comes down to is that
the things that have probability you
should think of ranges those are the
fundamental objects and it doesn't
really matter how we treat the boundary
and just think in terms of ranges even
still though what we're asking is a very
bizarre question which is if we take the
ratio of x and y and we round that down
which sometimes no mathematicians write
using this floor function saying we find
the greatest integer smaller than that
how do we know if that's an even number
that's a weird thing to think about it's
a hard problem in that way so you know
if you think through the principles here
it's kind of like use the defining
features of the set up well not clear
how to use the fact that it's a uniform
distribution I guess we'll be using
lengths in some way to yield
probabilities so maybe that gives us
some geometry but that's not really
helpful give things meaningful names you
know maybe x and y are meaningful or
some something suggestive like that
symmetry ok maybe you know the idea that
choosing X and then Y is as likely as
choosing Y than X you could use that to
conclude that this ratio x over Y is as
likely to be above 1 as it is to be
below 1 and that actually does tell you
something because if we're wondering how
often do you round down to be 0 right
you can say well x over Y is as likely
to be x is as likely to be bigger than Y
as Y is likely to be bigger than X so
there's a 50/50 chance that this should
happen this would be probability of si
percent so let gets you somewhere which
is kind of nice but it's not clear how
you would apply that to things like the
even numbers same object two different
ways unclear so principle number five
here is where we're going to come in
again it seems simple it's something
that you cannot along be like yeah yeah
drawing pictures it helps to think
through what I'm looking at but really
when you find yourself struggling with
some setup that's not already visual or
pictorial you know it doesn't have to be
making a geometric but just having some
kind of sketch to give meaning to your
terms can be very helpful and as a more
specific problem-solving tip when you
have some numbers multiple different
numbers see if you can make them
coordinates in some space so rather than
thinking about x and y is separate
things here we'll want to think about a
single point with XY coordinates and
what that does for us is it actually
turns the whole problem two-dimensional
in a very helpful way so first of all
I've lost track of my straightedge which
what have you gone little straightedge I
can only throw you so far here we go
things they run away from you even your
object sometimes get tired of math class
and want to play true into now and then
but he has to stay whether he likes to
or not I'm sorry so let's say this is
our x coordinate X can fall anywhere
between 0 & 1 with uniform probability Y
can fall between 0 & 1 so when we have a
pair of numbers you know something like
zero point two what does that maybe like
zero point eight pair of numbers is just
a single point in this diagram and now
to choose both of those numbers
uniformly at random means that we're
choosing a random point inside a square
a square with side length one and now
maybe we can make a little bit of
progress because it's going to come down
to some view of what's going on in this
square now with this specific example if
we're thinking about the ratio x over y
and taking its floor taking just
rounding it down
well that's 0.2 over 0.8 that's going to
round down to zero so this would end up
being even and like I just said that
that happens with 50% probability but
let's see if we can try to find a way of
thinking about that
that generalizes up to other examples
and again one very useful thing if you
get stuck but I have enumerated down
here as principle number six is to ask a
simpler variant of the problem you're
solving something it's hard it's too
hard see if you can make it simpler in a
way that you actually can solve and get
some kind of foothold maybe that means
loosening the constraints of the problem
in some setups or maybe it means looking
at a sub-problem so in our context
rather than asking the probability that
it rounds down to be even let me just
ask the probability that it becomes one
but I want you to answer it in a
geometric way is something that will
generalize to rounding to other things
because the next simpler question might
be probability that arounds down to two
and things like that you know where this
is gonna go we're gonna do it as a live
quiz because rather than me answering
things I want you guys to answer things
for me so jumping up to question number
four at this point it's going to give us
a couple different diagrams yeah we've
got a B C and E and it's asking us which
of these four regions corresponds to
values of x and y where X divided taking
the floor of X divided by Y is equal to
zero which is to say you take the ratio
you round it down you get zero which
region corresponds to that fact
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
okay I'm gonna go ahead and lock in
answers but if you want to keep thinking
about it definitely feel free to pause
the video and do so I don't want to rush
anyone
so looks like twelve hundred and sixty
five of you 1273 always answers rolling
in at the end correctly answered that
it's C and let's take a moment to think
about why that's the case yeah you can
do so just with a pile of examples and
just see which ones seem to fall in the
region or not but let's see if we can
understand this in a way that lets us
make progress on to the other even
numbers so when we say that it rounds
down to zero what we're basically saying
is that that ratio sits somewhere
between zero and one and it's awkward to
think of X divided by Y we kind of like
to think of Y in terms of X so if I
multiply everything by Y which is okay
to do with these inequalities because Y
is always positive so that's not going
to affect whether the inequality flips
one way or another I multiply everything
by Y and we're basically asking when is
X less than Y and whenever you see an
inequality the boundary of that region
is going to be described by the equality
so we're going to wonder when is it the
case that y equals x well that's just a
straight line that goes to agonal if we
draw our line y equals x that's what we
get now that's the boundary of our
region and to know whether we should
look to the left of it or to the right
of it either you can think very directly
and say well you know why should be
greater than X so at a given point we
want to move upward in the positive y
direction you could look at a specific
example like this but however you do it
you'll draw the conclusion that
geometrically the region of points such
that x / y rounds down to zero is this
sort of grilled-cheese cut of our
diagram so with that maybe you can start
to think about the harder variant which
is when is it that x / y rounds down to
be - and again I don't want to answer it
I want you to answer it when is it that
x / y inside our unit square of points x
comma y rounds down to two and we've got
four possible geometric regions that
this could
correspond to a B C and D and really you
know rather than just think about which
of these is it really try to think
through why it's the case and how you
can prove that one of these boundaries
is actually what it's supposed to be for
example I wanted to be the case that if
I didn't show the correct answer here
let's say I was just trolling with
everyone and I didn't show the correct
answer you would be able to confidently
come and say like no I'm quite positive
that the correct answer is nothing that
you've shown here see if that's the
level of reasoning that you can put
behind it so again I'll give you give
you a little moment to think about that
[Music]
you
[Music]
okay
so once again I'm gonna lock in answers
potentially earlier than you want me to
but keep the lesson moving forward
no hard feelings if things haven't
clicked yet because hopefully the
explanation will make them do so so the
correct answer is C which it looks like
most of you got and let's go ahead and
think through why that's the case very
similar reasoning to what we were just
doing the idea is that rather than
thinking about this ratio and a floor
which is kind of a kind of an awkward
thing
let's explicitly write out the
inequality this is referring to it's
saying that X divided by Y is greater
than or equal to 2 if it's rounding down
to that but it's not greater than 3 so
it's less than 3 and you know again it's
a little bit awkward to think of this
ratio so let's write that as 2 times y
is less than equal to X which is less
than or equal to 3 times y now quite
often we don't think of Y is a function
of X we think of X as a function of Y if
that makes you feel more comfortable so
if you want in the back of your mind you
can kind of think 2 y less than or equal
to X well that's the same thing as
saying Y is less than or equal to X
halves and same deal 3 y being greater
than X that's the same thing as saying Y
is greater than X divided by 3 because
that way we can look at the equality's
associated with each of these the line y
equals x halves which has a slope of 1/2
you can think of it as intersecting at
the point where y equals 1/2 when x
equals 1 so it'll be a line like this
that describes part of the boundary of
our region and the other line is when y
is equal to X thirds so we know we
actually have to be above this line that
I'm about to draw or one of these
represents x over 2 and one of these
represents x over 3 and then part of the
pardon the intrusion into the space of
my last inequality all right so we want
to be above the x equals x over 3 below
the X divided by 2 this region here
shows us everything we're rounding down
gets to 2 now what you appreciate how
this is a kind of complicated thing to
think about if we hadn't gone into a
picture that involves two dimensions if
you were just thinking of x and y
varying along this line and wondering
when is it the case that X is more than
twice or Y is more than two times what X
is now yeah sorry X is more than two
times or Y is but it's not three times
more than what Y is it's not no no I
said it wrong I said it wrong when y is
more than two times what X is but it's
not three times more than X is it's very
easy to get confront fuddled in that way
and it's even harder to try to give some
sort of probability to that whereas in
our diagram it has a very clear meaning
it is the area of this region because
the full area of the possibilities
already is one so these the probability
of something happening should be one and
we just need to look at the area of that
and now maybe you can see where this is
going to go because for the next term
when we want to know when is X divided
by Y sit between four and five we're
gonna be drawing lines that intersect at
x over four and you'll go to a different
color for this one x over four and x
over five which is going to require a
very small handwriting at this point but
I'm gonna give it a try nevertheless x
fourths y equals x fifths and this
little sliver of area gives us all of
the times that our ratio x over y rounds
to be four and we're gonna have to add
infinitely many of these so that gives
us sort of another phase of challenge to
the problem I've drawn this all out in
desmos by the way if you want to just
sort of see what some of these regions
look like where we've got our top region
of places where it rounds to zero then
we've got another region corresponding
to rounding to two rounding to four
rounding to six and just on and on each
one of these regions rounding and
rounding rounding I only went out to
like a hundred or something like that
but that gives you a sense of what we're
trying to do so we've made progress but
this is still hard what is the area of
all of those triangles added together
that's not necessarily an obvious thing
so let's just start by writing it out
and seeing what help that can give us so
every one of these is a triangle it's
gonna look like 1/2 base times height
and in fact every one of them if we
think of the left right direction as
being their height every one of them has
a height of one so each one is going to
look like 1/2 times a base of some kind
so I'm gonna take don't write this out
on a different piece of paper actually
so I can keep it up close I'll think 1/2
times whatever the base of the triangle
is times the height
so our first triangle that bases that
base has a length 1 so that's going to
correspond to the 1/2 probability of
going to 0 the next triangle we have to
look at this length here between 1/3 and
1/2 what is that length well actually
I'm just gonna write it out as 1/2 minus
1/3 it equals 1/6 but writing it out
like that kind of reminds us where it
came from so we don't want to collapse
things too soon that could maybe be
another problem solving tip don't
collapse things too soon and try to let
your notation have a memory for where
things came from because sometimes that
helps see overall patterns this next one
what's the distance between these two
points
well it's 1/4 minus 1/5 that's the
distance between these given how they
were defined so we have 1/4 minus 1/5
and in general we have this kind of
oscillating some 1/6 minus 1/7 where we
have all the reciprocals of the natural
numbers but we're adding in that up
infinitely many different times and we
want to know what that sound happens to
be and from here the the problem-solving
tip associated with this will seem a
little bit strange but it might be the
case that you recognize this fact from
somewhere else you might recognize let's
say if you were watching a particular
lock-down math lecture week or two ago
this alternating sum one minus 1/2 plus
1/3 minus fourth plus 1/5 on and on
actually equals the natural log of 2
okay and the way this actually came
about it's such a weird procedure it's
worth just like walking through again
really quickly because it's a bizarre
thing that you're not gonna you're not
gonna be able to just stare at this
formula and then immediately see that
this
how you're gonna solve it unless it's
something that you've seen before which
can make it seem all the more opaque we
did the strange thing where we made it
seem like a harder question at first
where rather than asking about one
particular sum we turned it into a
function which is effectively asking
about infinitely many different sums
like this so X to the fourth over four
then we're adding X to the fifth over
five and the reason for doing this is
that this plays nicely in calculus land
because those denominators are now
related to the exponents in a way that
we can kind of cancel out by doing an
integration trick each one of those
terms that can nicely express as an
integral of a much more simple monomial
term X cubed minus now let's see plus X
to the fourth if I integrate this thing
each one of them has an exponent that
increases and then we divide by what the
exponent is and the reason that you
would want to do this is that this now
has a nice way to collapse itself so
just to make this may be more explicit
if we evaluate the integral from 0 to 1
that's the same as taking this whole
expression and evaluating it at 1 and
subtracting at 0 so that will give us
what happens when we plug in at 1 and
again this is just such a bizarre thing
that if you hadn't recognized the sum
seeing someone prove it to you like this
doesn't necessarily make it feel like
something that you could have found
which is frustrating in the context of
trying to develop problem-solving tips
that are generalizable but I'll keep
walking through it just to give a little
bit of closure to this we've got this
infinite sum that if you had been
familiar with geometric sums where each
term looks like a certain product from
the last you would be able to write this
as 1 over 1 plus X because we're always
multiplying by negative x so you always
take 1 over 1 minus the thing you're
multiplying by which again it's kind of
one of these things where it's relying
on you recognizing it in some way and
then the last bit of recognition is
knowing how to take integrals of 1
divided by a thing and in this context
it works out very nicely to just be the
natural log and we're evaluating this
between 0 & 1
which is to say we're taking the natural
log of one plus one or two minus the
natural log of one which is zero and
that's why all of these things are the
natural log of two and think about what
has to go on there in order to be able
to take this and then apply it to a
probability question you would have to
recognize the alternating sum as
something that you had seen from another
context or if you didn't you would have
to be aware of this trick to somehow
turn it into a polynomial that can be
nicely expressed as an integral that can
be collapsed because of geometric series
which can be integrated because of the
natural log of X and then thinking about
like what is what is the thing that you
can teach someone to take say come away
and be able to solve problems in the
same way I have what might seem like
kind of a facetious tip but I actually
think it's maybe the most potent one and
the most honest one the way that you can
get to this sort of point just read a
lot read as much as you can you know
watch youtube videos on math if they're
substantive things like that and think a
lot about problems which is maybe
frustrating because what you want is to
be able to say like well how could I
have come to this on my own without
having nearly recognized it but I think
the truth of the matter is a lot of what
looks like insight and ingenuity is
really just pattern recognition but
wearing a little bit of added clothing
and sometimes it's patterns not so much
that you're directly recognizing exactly
this but maybe you had seen a series
like this or a tactic like this before
like geometric series that comes up a
lot if you read a lot and if you think a
lot about problems you will recognize
geometric series even if it's in a
context that you've never actually seen
before or a specific geometric series
that you've never seen before
similarly if you read a lot and you
think a lot about calculus knowing that
you can have the natural log pop out of
an integral like this it becomes second
nature and I think recognizing the truth
of this as being the key to a lot of
problem solving it's actually pretty
inspiring because often times you find
yourself in a situation where somebody
is they're just faster they're just
better they're just recognize things
more so than you do and that can be a
little bit intimidating right to look at
one problem think of yourself as pretty
savvy with math and knowing what's going
on and then just having someone burn
through with a wonderful bit of
cleverness this super beautiful argument
that leaves you sitting there in the
dust wondering like why
I just you know I'm just not in the same
league at all right and you sometimes
even think well he just has a math gene
right that person they just have some
sort of innate instincts that makes them
really good at this stuff but I think
the truth of the matter is the the
people who are showing that kind of
ingenuity they Virts expose themselves
to a huge number of patterns and you too
could get there right there is a path
towards that which takes the form of
practice but not just practice practice
where you're taking each problem that
you're looking at and trying to digest
the deeper principles behind it maybe
some of the ones I'm trying to talk
through today like okay I can say
leverage symmetry but what does that
actually mean you know what does it mean
to look at a symmetry of a problem and
turn that into something that's
formulaic ly useful you just have to see
it a lot and then be pensive when you do
don't just be satisfied with the answer
see if you can understand why that
answer came out so in that way this
number seven like it's it's the most
frustrating but it's the the most real
of all the problem-solving tips that
there can be which is that true
problem-solving comes down to a kind of
pattern recognition and there's no two
ways around it you just have to do a lot
of practice and expose yourself to a lot
now I would bet that when we did talk
about this infinite series a couple
lectures back you wouldn't have thought
that that's a thing that you're going to
be using in a probability question one
day but that's just how these things go
they show up in unexpected places
so what you can do then and say well
we've got our whole expression that
involves this very alternating sum and
you'd say okay that means that the
answer to our final question is you know
one half of the natural log of two it's
one half of what that alternating sum
came out to be which is very nice
you know it involves this natural log
expression and it's very clean and we've
got this picture for where it came from
adding up all of these all of these
areas now at this point there is one
thing that I think separates really good
problem solvers the ones who get like
nearly perfect scores all the time to
ones who are like merely good who you
know they aren't necessarily perfect
scores there's some like sealing
mistakes they come in here they're at
this point when you've done the problem
and you've got your nice elegant
solution you want to draw a box around
it you're not done just always always
principle number eight here always gut
check
your answer hey because there's gonna be
some little mistake that happens all the
time the great problem solvers aren't
the ones who just never make little
mistakes they're the ones who have some
way of recognizing what those mistakes
are so in this context let's say I I
just want to see numerically what my
answer turns out to be right we said
that it was 1/2 times the natural log of
2 so let's just see what does that end
up being and that 4 log of 2 is around
point 6 9 so maybe it's not too
surprising where around zero point 3 4 6
around 0.35 okay so if we write that
down as one of the is the answer that we
just got I told you I would purposefully
make a mistake so hopefully you're not
yelling too loud at this point does that
make sense does that pass a basic
reasonability test and if you look at
our picture well the probability has to
be at least 1/2 because that's the
region where it rounds down to 0 so
certainly it couldn't be the case that
the whole thing adds up to be only 0.35
so there must have been some mistake we
had along the way everybody makes silly
mistakes everybody drops a minus sign or
apply some rule that doesn't quite apply
in a circumstance you're not going to
make you're not going to approach
perfection by avoiding silly mistakes
the way to do it is to be able to
systematically know when you've when
you've made them so always go check your
answer have like 2 different
perspectives that can give you a reason
ability check in this context if it
inspired us to go and look a little bit
more carefully at how we were applying
things this sum isn't quite the
alternating sum that converges to
natural log of 2 in particular we added
the 1 but then we also add 1/2 and it's
only after that that we start
alternating it was plus plus than minus
plus minus plus on and on and you might
see this by recognizing we were
subtracting all the even numbers here
but we're subtracting all the odd
numbers here so it's similar but it's
not the same we will be able to use our
knowledge but let me just give this part
where things actually start alternating
a name something like s what this bottom
equation is telling us is that when we
take 1 minus s so that would mean we're
subtracting in 1/2 then we're adding the
1/3 then we're subtracting the 1/4 we're
flipping all of the signs of everything
beyond that 1 that is the thing that
equals the natural log of 2 which in
turn implies that
that remainder of the sum looks like one
minus the natural log of two okay so all
of that what does that tell us when we
plug it into our original expression
it's saying that the actual answer
should not be one half the natural log
of two that didn't even pay past our
basic reasonability test instead it'll
be one half of one plus one minus the
natural log of 2 which is just 2 minus
the natural log of 2 so does that pass
our reasonability check what does this
actually equal numerically you can get a
loose approximation in your head if you
want or if you want to see more
precisely we can pull up a calculator so
if we go over here and we're saying no
no we don't want the natural log of two
that was wrong too - that may be 0.65
three does that pass our reason our
basic reasonability test yeah I think so
all right 0.65 that looks like a
reasonable answer to what the area in
our in our diagram was because if we
looked at that diagram which was you
know we've got one wedge here that's
covering 0.5 and then this other one
covers well about one-sixth half of a
sixth basically because this length was
1/2 minus 1/3 which makes it a sixth and
then it's a triangle so 1/2 base times
height so that's about a twelfth or
point zero eight three and then the rest
of it you know it's not going to fill a
huge amount something around 0.65 seems
pretty reasonable and so that you know
we could call that good on our gut check
that this is probably the correct answer
but we could go one level further if we
wanted because probability questions
very often you can kind of cheat and
just see the answer by simulating it and
actually taking a bunch of samples and
seeing what happens so I want to do that
actually on this one just to give us a
little bit of confidence that our answer
of 0.65 that there wasn't some other
silly mistake that we made along the way
because everyone knows there certainly
are silly mistakes that we can make
before I jump to the programming though
I just want to see if there's any
questions from the audience and it
certainly looks like there are so let's
see if we can address some of these get
myself out of the way of the questions
this is like from the book of The Chosen
where the rabbi makes an intentional
mistake in his long
speech to test his son it is exactly
like that my children I just want to
test you every time I make a mistake it
was always purposeful and I was always
doing it just to test you I keep making
more episodes why am i stopping two
reasons
you know the main one honestly if I go
much longer in this lockdown without
getting a haircut we're gonna have to
start filming these in the style of like
a 1980s music video just to keep
stylistic consistency I'm not up for
that you know I think that's just gonna
be a little bit too much effort so I'll
have to wait until whenever it's
possible to get a haircut again then
then we can go really there I also just
missed my old content
I love visualizing stuff I've got a long
pile of things I want to get to and you
know the lectures take time I might spin
up something like this again I might do
it on a separate channel we'll see what
plays out but I would love to do like a
full course where it's a little bit more
clear exactly what we're going to talk
about from beginning to end
loosely I'm thinking like combinatorics
would be fun but don't hold me to that
and lastly can you help us understand
arrangements and the principles of
inclusion and exclusion just like
combinatory intuitive yeah boy how much
time do we have today tell you what
maybe just a separate video if I do the
combinatorics course actually that that
would be a perfect example for it it it
takes a little bit too much to describe
here but very naturally what you end up
with is taking 1 over 1 factorial minus
1 over 2 factorial plus 1 over 3
factorial minus and you're doing this
alternating sum with factorials which is
ye pops out and if you think of E is
fundamentally being the sum of the
reciprocals of factorials it doesn't
seem crazy surprising that it's related
to counting problems in that way but for
another day I'll say because I don't
know if we have time today because I
would love to just show how you could
maybe get check this programmatically if
you wanted to because the very last I
have principle I have for problem
solving for mathematical problem solving
is to learn at least a little bit of
programming okay and the reason here one
for what we're about to do you can
sometimes basically cheat and see what
an answer is numerically to see that
that verifies how you're thinking about
it analytically but also importantly it
forces you to think about things in two
separate ways sometimes you can go about
it mathematically
but then when you try to make it
computational you you run into certain
walls about like how are things actually
defined or I don't have infinity
available to me how can I do this in a
more approximate way very often when I'm
animating things for usual videos the
piece of math that I'm describing you
know it lines up with some way that I'm
programming it to give the illustrations
and windows mismatched that's actually
what's most interesting when it's not
computationally viable to give a perfect
illustration of what I'm describing and
I actually think that does make for
better problem solving in general where
you're coming at it from two different
angles so let's just try this out see if
we can understand the probability
question we were just looking at in
terms of just you know yeah what's the
word I'm looking for
cheating seeing seeing what it turns out
to be so I'm gonna import numpy which
evidently some heathens refer to as
numpy which just I just can't
that seems awful to me so we can find
random numbers if you just call random
this first random refers to the library
the second one is a function it will
return a number between 0 & 1 according
to a uniform distribution so it is as
likely to choose something between you
know zero point one and zero point two
as it is to choose something between
zero point eight and zero point nine and
what's nice is I can get a list of them
so in this case I get a list of ten
random numbers and maybe I call that
something like X and maybe I create
another list of Y so X some random
numbers Y some random numbers and if I
take X divided by Y it does it term by
term so for example this this first
number that we see in here that's point
seven three nine
that's taking the point five two divided
by the point seven this next one is
taking point six six divided by point
five six on and on so we can see all of
our ratios like that
and in general I might just define the
ratios list where I'm gonna take my a
bunch of random numbers of size N and
then divide it by another bunch of
random numbers of the same size and is
not too fine but I'll give it a
definition some nice and big number like
a million okay
and now I'm holding on to a million
ratios a million examples of X divided
by y where x and y are
chosen according to our constraints
which is kind of cool if you think about
it so you know we can see some examples
here some that have come up to 0 and
some that would round down to zero sum
that would round down to to some that
would round down to one so that's nice
and now I can start asking questions
like you know when is it that I take
these ratios I take the floor function
of them not the floor the floor and I
want to know when is that equal to zero
this gives me a list of trues and falses
basically saying it is or it isn't zero
and if I take the mean of that which is
treating the trues and falses as ones
and zeros this tells me the proportion
in total that will actually be zeros so
we expect it to be about a half and we
can verify yeah okay it's about a half
we could have also asked when is it
about to okay and it looks like 0.8 3
and remember from our diagram what we
were looking for is when when it's in
this green region here when it's in that
green triangle which has an area that
was 1/2 minus 1/3 but all times 1/2
because it's 1/2 base times height for a
triangle so if we pop back over to our
terminal and say ok if we were looking
for 1/2 times the base of that triangle
which was 1/2 minus 1/3
we would expect that proportion to have
been point 8 3 and yeah it looks like it
was about that and we could even answer
our actual question which is to take the
floor and then if I say I want to divide
by 2 and ask when the remainder is 0
that's a way of asking when it's even
and then taking that whole list and
taking a mean of it is a way of asking
how often that ends up looking like true
what proportion of them give me true and
yet point 6 5 which is about the answer
that we were looking for you know we
were looking for something that was 2
half of 2 minus the natural log natural
log of 2 so we have this this wonderful
way to kind of empirically verify and of
course in most of the times with in
lockdown map that I pulled a Python I'm
just doing relatively simple things
numerically if you wanted to you could
try to visualize stuff so something like
matplotlib is definitely a great pie
plot I'll import it as PLT this is a
very good library for
just like simple data visualization that
you can pull up pretty quickly so in our
context I can pull up a histogram so I'm
going to take a histogram of all of my
data and I have to specify a range so
maybe we just want to look at when the
when those values get bucketed in
between like zero and 20 so my number of
bins is 20 that was about to sneeze but
I held it in don't you love when that
happens when you're like a sneeze is
coming and you don't have to catch it it
just recedes into the darkness because
it knows that you're better than this
needs right again I'm more pleased with
myself than I should be there and I
always you always have to add a relative
width on these sorts of histograms
because they just look ugly if they're
all excited by side I think sometimes so
if I do this and then I show what the
plot ends up being I have something that
is shown up on my screen but not your
screen so let's pop it on over yeah
there we go so you can get a sense of
you know this bar represents all of the
ones that rounded down to zero and you
see it's about half of them about half a
million all the ones that round it down
to one rounded down to two and you can
get this nice nice sense for what all of
your data is again just adding that kind
of empirical validation on top of
whatever you find more analytically and
that back and forth I really do think is
helpful for more like pure mathematical
problem solving so with that that's
actually all that I have for the lesson
today just two quick things that I want
to go over before we end things here
I've been using decimals a lot to like
show graphs of things because I just
love desmos and I'm actually friends
with some of the people who work there
because quite often accompanies people
are as delightful as its products and
the CEO Eli
shared with me the fact that they were
doing like an art contest among some
students and I just wanted to showcase
some of I'm not sure if these are the
winners of the finalists of the art
contest but basically in various
different categories of students who
were I think it was like 12 to 14 15 to
17 or something like that
using like mathematical graphs to try to
draw pictures okay so keep in mind what
I'm about to show you our mathematical
graphs did someone wrote
just with an analytic description and
they were they were just prompted to
create something artistic from that okay
so one of my favorites and I think this
one was from someone named Carrie is two
giraffes that just from an artistic
standpoint it's actually quite lovely
and then to think through like actually
mathematically describing everything
involved here it's such a beautiful
blend of well like the creative side of
things the artistic side with aesthetics
and everything and the analytic side
another that was this is just genuinely
insane this is by a cat simi is a
Bayesian night so I definitely wanted to
highlight this on behalf of the team
over at desmos where each one of the
curves here is described according to
something that's called a Bezier curve
very useful for computer graphics it's a
kind of cubic parametric term and they
just recreated a starry night in a way
that's completely beautiful I think and
then the very last one which is
genuinely shocking that you can do with
mathematical graphs in any way was a
self-portrait by Jared that's just like
genuinely insane I mean I remember
playing around with like a ti-84 and
trying to come up with little pictures
of like a smiley face and things like
that so the amount that things have
changed in terms of when someone's
noodling off with their graphing
calculator in class and what they can do
truly next level and then at the very
end I just want to say again like a
highlighted thank you to Ben eater and
to cam who've been extremely helpful
with the whole series in ways that's
like hard to even articulate properly
eater in particular I mean he's let me
borrow a lot of his equipment and helped
out with like figuring out live footage
type stuff because that's not something
I usually do which is not even to
mention the work on the live stats and
live quizzes so if you aren't already
familiar with his channel
that's simply named Ben eater like 100%
check it out definitely subscribe to it
try some of the projects he has a very
project oriented way of teaching I think
it's absolutely great so cannot
emphasize enough how how grateful I am
in the direction of both of those two
and check out the the item pool site
where we are going to let you kind of
relive the lockdown math experience and
have like homework
all challenges associated with each one
of them so stay tuned on that and if
you're interested in being a beta user
of it there will be forms for how you
can how you can reach out to both of
them thank you everyone for joining in
the whole series this has been very fun
for me very different for me and I will
shortly get back to the more usual
videos which I'm very excited about
there's a couple topics that I just
think you're thoroughly gonna enjoy
especially if you like problem-solving
stuff like this like really getting into
good meaty problem-solving that's some
of what's on the horizon and with that I
will simply say keep loving math and
enjoy the rest of your day
[Music]
[Music]